[Music]
you
you
confidence and communication is critical
to business success and it's a really
simple equation confidence equals
competence the more confident you come
across the more competent people will
see you as and the more credible they'll
see you as so we really need to work to
make sure that we're confident many of
us get very anxious and high-stakes
communication situations via giving a
presentation running a meeting or even
having an important interpersonal
conversation so we need to learn to
manage our anxiety and I use that word
very carefully we don't want to overcome
it anxiety actually helps us it gives us
focus it gives us energy but we want to
manage it so it doesn't manage us and
when it comes to managing that anxiety
we need to take a two-pronged approach
we need to first focus on the symptoms
and what we show people in terms of our
anxiety and second we need to work on
the sources what actually causes that
anxiety so let me give you an example
many people when they get nervous they
feel their heart rate beating very fast
and they begin to perspire or blush this
happens to me
and a great way to manage those symptoms
is first to take some deep belly breaths
in doing that you slow down your heart
rate in addition you get yourself
breathing in a lower place which allows
you to support your voice better so you
don't have a shaky quivering voice as
many nervous people do in terms of the
blushing and the sweating that's because
you're actually getting hotter when you
speak and are nervous about speaking
your core body temperature goes up just
like you have a fever and a great way to
manage that much like you do when you
have a fever is to make your self cooler
now you're not gonna hold a cold
compress on your forehead when you're
giving a presentation but you could hold
something cold in the palm of your hands
[Music]
we need to think about what is driving
us to be nervous for many of my students
and the people I coach it has to do with
for example the future consequences of
what they're trying to do many of us
when we speak in high stakes situations
were worried about not achieving our
communication goal if I'm an
entrepreneur I might want funding or
advice if I must one of my students I
might want a good grade or to perform
well on my assignment and because we're
worried about the future consequences we
get very nervous so a great way to
manage that source is to actually focus
on the present moment be present while
speaking how do you do that well before
you start speaking do something physical
take a walk around the building shake
hands with people in the audience get
yourself in the moment you know athletes
before they perform their sport they
listen to a playlist or a song to help
them focus speakers can do the same
thing my secret to get present-oriented
as I love saying tongue twisters it
sounds silly but saying a tongue twister
forces you to be in the present moment
and it also warms up your voice many
nervous speakers they don't take the
time to warm up so if you want to be
more confident when you present you need
to focus both on the symptoms and the
sources to help
[Music]
we have to start by thinking about what
is our communication goal and a
communication goal has three parts it's
what do you want your audience to know
when you're done how do you want them to
feel you want them to feel excited you
want to feel concerned or just confident
and what do you want them to do if you
have that speaking goal not only will it
direct everything that you're saying but
at the end of a presentation even if
you're cut off towards the end you
should be able to recite that speaking
goal and it's a nice way to wrap things
up so you could say something like the
bottom line is I want you to know that
it's critical to prepare for your
communication and be confident in
delivering it I want you to feel really
empowered that you can do that and give
meaningful presentations and
communication and ultimately I want you
to put this into practice the single
best way to be more concise and more
directed to your audience is to have
clear structure in what you're saying
when we ramble when we are putting our
thoughts together as we're speaking
that's when we risk talking too much and
turning our audience off it's much
better to start with a speaking goal
what is it I want my audience to know
feel and do when I'm done and then put
that information into a structure my
favorite structure is the what so what
now what structure I explain what my
point is I explain next why it's so
important that's the so what and then
the now what is what I'd like you to do
with it having a structure like that not
only helps me more be more confident
because I know how I'm going to say what
I want to say but it also keeps me very
concise because once I'm done I'm done
there's no need to say more
[Music]
in terms of presentations I am on a
personal mission to help people stop the
most common way of starting which is hi
my name is and today I'd like to tell
you about and the funny thing for me and
that is most of the time when people
start that way what's behind them but a
slide projecting their name and the
title of their presentation it's a
wasted opportunity I would much rather
people start their presentations or even
their meetings in some kind of
interactive way ask a question take a
poll give some startling statistic or
perhaps tell a story all of those are
ways to pull your audience in I like to
joke that a good presentation starts
like a James Bond movie not with all the
action in the violence but it starts
with something that gets you attached
right away and then after that you see
the title and the credits for the movie
presentation should start that way to
start with something that draws your
audience in and then step back and say
your name and your relationship to the
topic and in terms of ending we know
that both primacy that's what happens
first in recency that's what you hear
last are really critical so when you end
a presentation or you end a
communication make sure you sum up your
key ideas but help your audience to
understand what they can do with it and
why it's important that they do that the
most common way I hear presentations end
in the business world where I do my
consulting is hope somebody else has got
the room we got to leave or in my
classes people just say I guess I'm out
of time thanks those are missed
opportunities so really think about how
to end with something memorable and
something that summarizes your key ideas
[Music]
nonverbal communication is really
important people make assessments of
your credibility and form impressions
within milliseconds of seeing you some
really simple rules around what to do in
terms of your nonverbal presence
fundamentally it's about being big
balanced and still and by big I mean you
want to be upright you don't want to
make yourself smaller when we're nervous
and concerned we make ourselves small
and constrict we want to be big we want
to be balanced meaning our head is
straight our shoulders are square we're
not leaning we're not resting
additionally we want to be still when we
get nervous we fidget our hands move our
legs shake we want to make sure that we
seem composed so the biggest thing to
make a very effective quick impression
in terms of your confidence is to be big
balanced and still when it comes to your
hands you want them to be expansive that
is you want them to go beyond your
shoulders a lot of people carry they're
at their hands up tight and in front of
them it's a very defensive posture so we
want to make sure that we're out and
that when we're not gesturing our hands
are still in calm those are by far the
most important nonverbal postures we can
take to convey confidence
[Music]
making mistakes while speaking is normal
and natural we're human beings one thing
to do is not call attention to it not
focus on it sometimes when when I make a
mistake I'll just say I'm just so
excited about this topic I get ahead of
myself
let's go back and start again other
times what I'll do is I'll just ask the
audience a question so if I find myself
floundering or if I've made a mistake
I'll stop and say let's take a moment to
reflect on the value of what we've
discussed so far what does this mean for
you
and while they're thinking or perhaps
I'll have them even turn to the person
next to them and exchange their answers
that gives me time to reset and get
myself back on course there are times
where people in your audience can be
challenging for you it could be they're
asking a difficult question perhaps they
have a disagreement with something
you've said or they just want to air
their point of view that can be very
challenging the the difficulty for you
is not only handling that person in a
respectful polite way but you also have
to be very cognizant of your audience's
perception of how you manage that so I
like to say you know I have two kids and
they like to play lots of video games
and in their video games their
characters have life points above their
head and as they do more poorly they
lose those life points as a speaker you
have credibility points above your head
and if you handle a situation like that
poorly you lose credibility to me the
most valuable tool to help deal with
hecklers or challenging people is
paraphrasing listen to what they're
saying for for a little bit then
paraphrase what they've said and move on
so it might be something like I clearly
hear you have some passion on this topic
and I appreciate your feedback but what
I'd like to do is address and what I've
done is I've acknowledged their energy
perhaps their their emotion and then
I've redirected to the next place I'm
going I've been known in meetings where
somebody gets me up in my face I've been
known to say thank you for sharing
clearly you're very passionate I'm
curious to know what somebody on this
side of the room thinks about where I
just take the floor away and for
communicators that can feel rude but not
doing that is being rude to the rest
the audience so you have to be very
aware of not just how you treat the the
Troublesome individual but all the
others in the audience a wonderful
mindset to have when communicating is
that this interaction I'm about to have
be it a big keynote or an interpersonal
interaction this is one of opportunity
this is one where I have an opportunity
to share my thoughts my beliefs my
feelings and it's one where I get to get
information back from my audience many
of us see speaking as a threat or as a
challenge and when you see that you
become very defensive and that manifests
itself in our body in terms of being
tight and constricted and it manifests
us in our willingness to share into to
go deeper into the information that we
want to convey so having a mindset of
this is an opportunity this is something
where I can share and I can learn from
others really makes a big difference
[Music]